so you know most people don't understand
nfts right nfts what is an nft
non-fungible token what the hell is that
people still don't know what an nft is
you can't blame them yeah you can't
blame it
by the way there's a lot of people that
still don't even know what a
cryptocurrency blockchain they're still
trying to learn what this is going on
this is on a whole different level kai
did you find a story or not that i
emailed you
check this out guys this is this is
seriously insane to me
okay when i show this to you i hope your
reaction is as crazy as my reaction is
when i saw this story
italian artist sells an invisible
structure for more than
a sculpture for more than eighteen
thousand dollars
you have to see the picture by the way
go up see if the picture is there where
he's standing there
that's the sculpture
he's sold i'm not kidding with you the
italian sculpture sold an
invisible sculpture for 18 200
this is this is the era we're living in
can you imagine guys says
it's yours take it you
take it watch your step watch your step
my sculpture's here
hey you know what hey here's the problem
half the left would be offended by it
oh my gosh italian can you italian
artist gets away with money laundering
that's the actual sculpture that's sold
for look at look at how beautiful that's
going to press
press play just right there just lower
your audio guy look at that beautiful
18 grand right there let your
imagination run wild unbelievable
unbelievable now buddha in contemplation
milano sculpture whatever souls sells
for 18 000
in the middle what am i doing wrong this
is what am i
those guys made you know they're doing
an ft on
the video you know everything every
everywhere there's people work 12 hours
a day in this office
they're going to see this and they're
just going to break down in tears you
remember the movie dropped at fred
do you remember when that guy had his
imaginary friends like 30 40 years ago
it's actually a really good movie it's a
funny movie so
folks today who imagine like my son is
one that says you know he imagines he
has a certain friend or he has
certain things today you can imagine say
i own the largest castle in the world
and i'm willing to sell it to you for a
million dollars
it's and it's right there take a break
it's right there yeah right beautiful
you know one time my uncle my uncle my
uncle had a very very
uh uh unique sense of humor like a yogi
berry sense of humor so
but he couldn't stand arrogant rich
people my uncle my dad's brother
so one day they're hanging out with a
few friends i've told the story a few
times
they're hanging out with a few friends
and everybody's bragging one guy says
yeah i own a bunch of pecan dealerships
pecan and iran is like toyota dealership
it's a french car but pecan dealers oh
wow that's great
how about yourself yeah i won't know
multiple hotels you know great
how about yourself i want a waterfront
property how about yourself i have this
so finally it comes to my uncle now my
uncle owns nothing the only thing he
owns is a deck of cards
that's it he knew how to play poker and
that's he was a hustler right
and he drove slow he walked slow
everything about him
was slow everything was slow but the
funniest guy in our family
so he's sitting there my dad sitting
there like oh my gosh we own nothing
what the hell are we going to say so
my uncle uh victor says uh you know
we have we have a lot of land and he
says really he says that we have a lot
of land
he says where's your land at he says in
the center of caspian sea
we own a thousand acres of land clever
guys
really says yeah our family david family
we own a thousand acres of land in the
middle of caspian seasons what are your
plans with it
when it dries up we're going to build a
hotel on top of it
and by the way it's not laughing so
they're walking away saying how the hell
do you
own a thousand acres of water i love
jasmine
my uncle today would have been a
billionaire convincing people he owns a
thousand acres
way easier way easier to have an nfd
of cats well with climate change being
the way it is we think it'll be seven or
eight months before the caspian sea
dries up
so shout out to the person that sold
that you know sculpture man
that is money laundering right i mean
that that's just what it is i mean it
has to be look i thought i was a good
salesperson but officially i just met
the greatest salesperson hey that's the
free market though
he needs to write a book he needs to
write a book write a book on selling i
will buy it i promise you i'll be the
first person to buy that book
i hate when they give the socialist ammo
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]